Okay.
What is logic?
I'll admit I will have difficulty finding
a straight forward way of defining
what logic is that will satisfy everyone
who uses it and everybody who studies
it.
But if you weren't watching this video
with me asking that question right now,
you'd probably head over to
your favorite no, it all site.
You know the one I'm talking about and
it would tell you that logic deals with
valid reasoning. Perhaps we
could call it structured thought,
maybe even well structured thought.
I'll return to that difference
between reasoning and reasoning. Well,
since that split does come up in the
historical back and forth dialogue on how
to conceptualize and understand logic,
but first let's travel back to but one
of the ancient peoples who started to
talk about logic explicitly and use it to
hone their language in their arguments.
In Ancient Greece,
there lived a talkative and thoughtful
fellow who was socially awkward enough
that he failed to respect
conversational boundaries,
yet smart enough that he knew how to
call people out on their full of ships.
This is of course Socrates who
actually didn't claim he was so smart.
He went around asking folks
about presumably basic
topics like courage and self
control, claiming that he didn't
really understand these himself.
He asked a parent experts to walk him
through the details so that he could come
to understand them at least a little bit,
but as Plato tells it,
these initially light conversations go
from bad to worse as the experts can't
manage.
She gives Socrates a solid case for
their own perspectives on these topics.
In fact,
they're routinely forced to admit that
they don't really know what they're
talking about,
but more than an ancient tale
of intellectual upmanship.
This is among history most iconic
demonstrations of logic, inaction
in a logical nutshell,
attempting to define words and sentences
meaningfully and precisely structuring
sentences into an argument and checking
to make sure that that argument and
those meanings produce a coherent line
of reasoning that has a shot at drawing a
true conclusion
like other figures in
other ancient societies.
Socrates shows us that we
can be thoughtful and precise
in a way that allows us
to build a solid argument and
come to a specific conclusion.
But there's a catch.
That cost is because our thoughts
are explicit and not vague.
Our argument can be evaluated and
corrected just as precisely and we can be
shown where we're wrong.
On the other hand,
our thoughts can remain vague and we can
remain free of any need to argue for a
point,
but then we have no reason to think of
the right so it's shallow of us to hold
that a certain precise conclusion is true.
This was the mistake of the
friends Socrates like to chat with.
They assume they had something figured
out but had never really thought about it
logically.
Aristotle put this way of thinking
under his scrutiny as best he could see,
he could reduce logical thinking
to a basic set of structures.
The basic structure of an argument was
for Aristotle the syllogism and it runs
something like this.
If a is B and if B is c,
then a his seat. You can fill in a, B,
and c with your own favorite terms
to see what he was getting at.
Here's my preference.
If little Russian nesting doll fits
inside medium Russian nesting doll and
medium Russian nesting doll fits
inside big Russian nesting doll.
Then little Russian nesting doll
fits inside big Russian nesting doll.
All men are mortal. Socrates is
a man, so Socrates is mortal.
It may seem basic,
but in all syllogism we can use to
supporting pieces of information to draw a
novel conclusion that's not
in that information already.
This conclusion gets called an inference.
Okay.
We've used Socrates to look at logic as
a way of tightening up our understanding
of a topic,
the contents of our reasoning,
and we've used Aristotle to view
logic as a way of structuring thoughts
regardless of their contents,
the form of our reasoning.
That's second part of logic called
formal logic has done a lot to shape the
makeup of logic over the centuries by
thinking abstractly with variables and
operators to connect them.
Magicians have contributed to
developments in mathematics,
computer science and many other endeavors.
Rewind to that syllogism stuff.
Logically,
this structure is considered valid.
That should mean it always works, right?
Not so fast. Look, look,
we can fill it in with some strange stuff.
The conclusion doesn't actually have to
be true for us to call this structure.
Logical,
valid logic gives us true conclusions.
If we have true information to begin with.
Verifying the accuracy of
your content means well,
doing your homework on whatever
it is you're arguing about.
We have so many disciplines that study
specific topics rigorously and in detail.
Meteorologists aren't stuck imagining
the reasonable possible conclusions they
can come to about the weather.
They can use logic to come to specific
conclusions backed by their observation
and historians don't just think about
logically possible sequences of events in
the past, but argue for specific
chronologies based on their studies.
It's still logic.
It's still logical,
but the content is as specialized as the
tools and methods used by the experts
in these fields.
If you've been paying attention,
as much as I expect anyone to pay
attention to some video on the Internet,
you at least get that logic has something
to do with how we think about stuff.
Maybe you even gathered that it has much
more to do with the thinking about part
than the stuff.
Pardon?
Way To keep up in all this thinking.
Does logic describe our thought process,
like an objective observer might or does
it judge our reasoning telling us how
we ought to think like an
impassioned partisan wood? Well,
some hopefuls have seen logic as at
least potentially a kind of physics of
thought. It's usually treated and
defined more like an ethics of thought.
It doesn't dictate how we think, only
how we should think if we want to reason.
Well,
that doesn't make logic subjective
in the sense of ultimately just up to
anyone's whims.
It just means that since we can be
logical or illogical in our thinking,
we've got to work at it.
If we want to be logical.